is
all right summer
Bridge girl where are you from
originally I am from Oakland California
Oakland yeah tell me about your family
growing up you had both mom and dad you
know I unfortunately lost my dad in
2019.
how'd you lose your dad
uh heart problems
how old are you I'm 20. you're 20.
almost
how would you describe your childhood my
childhood
um
it was kind of like
it was weird I could say it's it's not
like everybody else
like everybody got a different type of
childhood and stuff like that
mines I would say
um
[ __ ]
they were just like sorry abuse
uh no not towards me
so
no no
how far are you in school how far did
you go in school how far did I go to
school I actually graduated high school
you did what kind of kid were you in
high school
um I was the one that I
I was fighting a lot as they suspended
um for fighting and [ __ ]
um but then I calmed down when I got
into High School
so yeah
but you graduated but I graduated
even doing this kind of work for how
long I've been on this about a year
but I've been knowing about it
my whole life you saw girls on the
street doing it no just because I
I just been knowing about it like I the
like of people I associate myself with
is that right
how'd you first get introduced to it
um I actually introduced myself to it
you decided there's something you want
to do yeah because it's like I put two
of them together like I'm not about to
be [ __ ] these [ __ ] for free and
they all heard treating me like [ __ ]
like it's like
are you about to pay for it now so
that's what I'm do you figure that if
the alternative is just a
be having
sex for free and being treated badly you
might as well just make money yeah might
as well make money out of it
what kind of relationships did you see
when you were a kid between like your
mom and I mean your dad was gone your
dad was around for some of your life
they wasn't together no they weren't but
did you see any relationships that you
could use as role models
my role model was my is my big brother
yeah my twin
you remember your first date what your
first trick you picked up
yeah it was out here
in L.A
it was good
how much money you make
oh remember
but I'll be making money out here I like
la like that's why I'd be like coming
back here a lot like so you you live in
Oakland but you come down here to work
how much money are you making a night
typically
it depends where I'm at how the night is
do you have a pet
yeah I got folks so is there a quota
what was that is there a quota of what
you're supposed to make a night yeah
yeah
which is what roughly
I thought it'd be disclosing all like no
you don't want to talk about it no right
understood
have you had bad things happen to you
you had guys pick you up and try to rob
you and stuff like that oh yeah
it doesn't get you to quit huh it
doesn't make you want to quit no I just
go give me a shot a hit of wood and go
back outside yeah
and drugs are part of your life
I wouldn't say drugs is a part of my
life but it's like
[ __ ] is something that I like like to
you know do like to smoke weed and [ __ ]
that's the only thing I do smoke weed
and drink but yeah you have to drink or
smoke in order to do this kind of work
no I'll be outside sober as well yeah
you go out during the day or at night
I'll be outside all the time
you got to make that quota gotta make
that quota
do you have dreams of doing something
else with your life you're still so
young
I am most definitely it does you think
this is just a temporary thing you're
gonna do for a while and then duh this
is a temporary thing like I'm not about
to be and I'm not about to be 28 and
still on fig that's out
that's out
you know
none whatsoever like I got plans for
myself my folks got plans for me so it's
like
I'm good
what kind of plans does your dude have
for you elevation like I'm elevating
like like doing [ __ ] [ __ ] don't
even think about like
yeah so
no kids right no kids
does your mom know you're doing this
yeah
what you think of it
uh of course she ain't gonna approve of
it but hey that's this is my life what
Mom would
I don't know but this is my life so
if I decided I want to go outside and
pop mock with you
go outside and pop my coochie
you bring your you're doing all your
money
what was that you bring your dude all
your money
I wouldn't say all that
yeah
next question
what's your favorite kind of John
huh what's your favorite kind of date
trick
uh-huh I like the junk Mexican ones
it's like lots of those unfig yes I like
those it's a state bird down there um
I like the junk Mexican ones
for what reason
easy to break
just kind of work it get to you after a
while
does this kind of work get you down
do it get you down yeah just get you
depressed or angry or anxious or
anything like that yes yeah I do it
gives me like irritation times because
like it don't be moving away a hobby
want to move but you know you just got
to stay down and stay consistent and
[ __ ] like that and then it's just it's
gonna come forward it's going to push
through you're gonna pull in with you
again
what you've been wanting so you just
gotta stay down like there's gonna be
times where you do feel lonely you do
feel like you
like uh I'm over this [ __ ] like but not
just stay down because it's gonna be
it's gonna be good on the other side so
there's a promised land down the road
yeah something something good at the end
of this there's some together and you
just gotta stay down
but you're lonely sometimes huh you're
lonely sometimes
well don't get lonely but hey they get
out yeah join the club
how does this kind of work affect you
your self-esteem does it build it up or
does it you know because the guys are
always driving by saying how beautiful
you are
um
tear myself seen Down I actually build
it up because it's like I'm a bad [ __ ]
so it's like I like to actually get
dressed up so if I can get dressed up
and walk down the street and make money
and that's what the [ __ ] I'm about to do
it's got like a fashion show for always
exactly so it's like
hey
but then you have girls out there and
sweatpants and flip-flops and yeah
that's them that's how they feel they
feel like they're beautiful in
sweatpants flip-flops hey that's how
they feel
I feel like I'm a bad [ __ ] with some
inches some some hills
in a damn slingshot
what's the best thing that's ever
happened to you out there
that's the best thing that ever happened
to you yeah yeah some guy spent a lot of
money on you or like that yeah there's
times where I got a lot of money out of
one jig and I had like it was cool
there was times it was like bro wow
getting your car
so
yeah
what's it what's I mean do you like
dream about getting like a sugar daddy
who's a regular and he gives you lots of
money
I want to say I dream of it
because I was like yeah but I would say
like I am like I would I wouldn't mind
having a sugar daddy
because if I get a couple of sugar
daddies then be cool
you better love have I ever been in love
yes
um
um I don't know
well no no I haven't we can just stop
now
good about your folks what about your
dude
what what about your dude do you not
love you Mama folks yeah I got a special
he got a special place in my heart like
I'm always having his back throughout
whatever I could ask my folks to
whatever like I got his back through
whatever
so you do got a special place in my
heart
what would you say is the most
misunderstood thing about girls that do
this kind of work
because people are driving on the street
thinking oh they're just a bunch of
they can think whatever they like yeah
they just be like I don't know like
people be like oh
why don't you just go out there go get a
9-5 but you gotta understand some
females is not some females is used to
fast money so your weekly paycheck that
you get in at the end of the week that
[ __ ] she probably making that [ __ ] in
that night and more
so it's like
you like if a [ __ ] is used to fast
money then she gonna stick to the fast
money I'm not like she's not about to go
back to be no Square bitching over to
being nine to five and but okay I gotta
wait to the end of the week I gotta
stretches like living to paycheck to
paycheck like that's done like that's
out
like that's weird that's annoying that's
frustrating that's depressing okay
that's a quick ask for me I will fall
into the depression real quick because
it's like
oh I get paid on Friday and then I get
paid on Friday I gotta pay all these
bills and they'd be like damn I got no
more money like what the [ __ ] like no
that's out so
I feel like people just need to
understand like some people is not meant
for the nine to five lifestyle right
some people just they want the fast
money lifestyle so they just need to
accept the fact and just leave them for
like leave leave [ __ ] alone
like leave these [ __ ] alone
harassing them like wow she'll get 9-5
oh well what's wrong with that like bro
mind yours okay if you're fine living
like that you're fine living like that
I'm fine living like this leave me alone
there's no going back for you
no like I'm used to it
are you addicted to the fast money
sounds like you are yeah I really am I
ain't gonna cap I am like I'm Addicted
to Money I'm
I am addicted to money
is it strange sometimes to be in this
environment where
everybody's doing something
shady I mean like like
you know the whether it's the tricks or
The Pimps or the cops even or the other
girls everyone's up to something Shady
you guys want to watch a bit
so it's like I won't be just nobody so
when I was like I don't trust somebody
so I'm always watching my back I'm
always on my team so I'm always watching
my bag like
um I always got eyes on me so it's like
I won't be just nobody like y'all not
about to catch me
as well
if I feel anything off I'm on the phone
like ready dear friends
yeah awesome I would say yeah
would it be easy for you to walk away
from this one day
you think when you're when you're ready
to get out
at the right old age of 25 you think
you'll if I'm making as much if I'm
making more money than I am now doing
something else
still making life fast money type [ __ ]
then yeah I walk away from this like for
instance if I got my own business and my
business is bringing twice as more money
I'm bringing in a night then yes I will
stop and go full force pledge into my
business or I will go find something
else to
basically find another income so it's
not like I'm gonna just stop this wait
and it don't have no income coming I'm
gonna have to make sure I have a plan
before I'll be like okay I'm officially
I'm officially put the heels down
and do something else you realize that
most of the girls are still doing this
in their 40s yes hey
stem okay wish them the best
what have you learned about men from
doing this kind of work what I learned
about men by doing this kind of work
yeah
um
I learned that
they care about their money they want
their money don't give up one nothing
you don't got their money and I'm gonna
talk to you and I'm gonna like no yo
trapping looking right [ __ ] y'all have
to stand outside so that [ __ ] is looking
right and yeah so it's just like all I
learned that they [ __ ] they like their
money [ __ ] we all like money but what
about your tricks what about your
clients my drinks what I learned about
them
um most of them are married
man all these [ __ ] out here
ready they got a girlfriend yes
but I learned uh I know that a lot of
Mexicans like black girls
um
that lately been my um
my clientele has been Mexicans and I do
I love my Mexicanos you speak Spanish
a little bit a little bit you're
learning a little bit
what advice would you give to a young
girl who's
thinking about doing something like this
this game is not for the week
of the week we mentally [ __ ] with you
emotionally [ __ ] with you she physically
[ __ ] with you like [ __ ]
um just know when you go
into this [ __ ] you pick the right folks
the right isn't because autism ain't
good ISM like all that like like if you
got boyfriend pimps you got whole
Hustlers then you got realism and it's
like all these boyfriend pimps and uh ho
Hustlers is it's so many of them
[ __ ] it's like you can't see
which one is the real isn't so it's like
I say no it's night and day huh and
they're like night and day exactly so
just like I just tell you you do get in
this game make sure you this is
something you really want to do
and that you choose the right ISM
because like I said autism ain't good
ism like you will be sending like you
will be sitting here
thinking like damn I've been here for
[ __ ] five years I'm still looking at
the same [ __ ] pair of shoes
what the [ __ ] is going on like
shoddy
go
go like
so
you get risky requests to get guys
asking to do without a condom and stuff
like that yeah a little nasty ass
[ __ ] I'm sorry
I'm not but they nasty like bro what
makes you think like we'll possess y'all
to sit there go outside well not you but
like what makes y'all go outside and be
like yeah I'm gonna go find a random
[ __ ] and I'm gonna [ __ ] that [ __ ] Raw
that [ __ ] probably got AIDS herpes
chlamydia gonorrhea anything you could
die from a disease and you want to go
out there and risk that [ __ ] [ __ ] bye
or a [ __ ] buy most of your clients are
probably high or drunk or something like
that
um I'll be getting a little Coke some
little cold cakes once I be trying to
like they'd be like you want something
you like to party no
I'm getting some of those so
the dog yeah
a lot of you guys just want to grow the
party with yeah I'm not that girl
they're gonna party with though because
I don't do that
do you have any regrets in your young
life
nope everything happened for a reason
I'm learning from it so what's the most
important thing you've learned in your
20 years most important thing I learned
is to love myself
um
myself love take care of myself that's
the worst first thing I like is that's
the most important thing I learned is to
take care of myself love myself because
at the end of the day
I'm the only one I got so it's like
I gotta make sure I'm good because I'm
the one that's gonna be going six feet
in that damn casket I'm not about to
have my folks with me or like my wife
you're something like that so it's like
so I just gotta love myself that's great
all right summer thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you you're the
best of luck
thank you